we've been inside pretty much non-stop
for the last two weeks
Natalie Francis is holed up at home
we're not even going down to put the
rubbish out
it's just she's had enough and wants to
leave Wuhan the Foreign Office offered
her a flight back
but wouldn't take her three-year-old who
doesn't have a passport what was your
reaction when you were told you had the
place but not your son
disbelief really I respect that the man
is just trying to do his job in it and
it must be an awful difficult job at
this time but no being asked to you and
to abandon your son and come back to UK
it's just there's there's no words
there's literally no words but even
those do to fly home a struggling Antony
May Smith has been visiting his
girlfriend he has a seatback confirmed
but isn't convinced he'll make it the
situation is still the same you know
they're still waiting for a confirmed
time you know it could be early hours
but you know we could get a phone call
while we're asleep and if we miss the
phone call then we've missed the flight
other countries have already repatriated
their citizens the UK flight is expected
on Thursday the government says
passengers will be placed in safe
isolation for two weeks but we don't
know how or where that's happening the
government flying Britain's back from
Wuhan to the UK shows their commitment
to protecting British citizens and I
don't think that the British public need
to have any concern about it because
they aren't a risk to the British public
and the government has already announced
that they are going to isolate them for
14 days and make sure they don't develop
any symptoms another emergency Cobra
meeting took place by discussing the
UK's plan and the World Health
Organization will again debate whether
this is a global health emergency
British Airways joined other carriers
canceling flights to and from mainland
China no more planes for two days the
asked passengers arriving earlier when
we left they actually had sent the best
way to stop the spread
yeah getting even how serious it is
situation right as the UK is poised to
fly people home governments around the
world are stepping up their response as
the global effort to contain the virus
grows Nora bundle Sky News